MVP I
love you I love you Each and every one I
love you I love you, I love you Painting the future we seek Never stop your dreaming I think colors are light The stage, fill the world We're miracles MVP Let's go
Previously.
Oh my god.
Am I dead?
God.
Oh god, what do ghosts even do?
Do I say boo?
Do I say bleh?
Oh god.
What's this?
Get a job.
Excuse me?
Get a job?
Oh my god.
The audacity.
a moment to...
Oh my gosh!
Game!
I think I better get out of this weird forest.
I don't know why I am here.
But, um, I think the computer just set on fire, so, uh, let's just find the nearest town and, uh, set up shop.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, listen, listen, listen, everybody, everybody, everybody!
I think I've got it.
I think I finally nailed it.
I think I finally have the sound!
You have to listen, okay?
Everybody, everybody gather!
Everybody gather and listen, please!
Okay, okay, okay, here I go!
She's really good!
No, no!
It's all wrong!
I just can't get this sound right!
What's wrong with me?
Sorry, guys.
I don't know, recently it just feels like...
It just feels like...
It just feels like I haven't really...
Found my place yet, you know.
Don't really know where I belong.
I guess that's kind of the problem with being a ghost, huh?
It's just, I think it would be a lot of fun if I could find some friends to create music with, you know?
I feel the May Cafe would be pretty lively then.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm just feeling some ghostly blues, you know?
The booze!
But I know of you guys are here with me, too.
It'll still be a really fun time, so...
Thank you.
Let's take it from the top again!
Hey!
Oh!
Oh yeah.
Break it down.
Um, yeah.
He's still there.
Staring at me.
Menacingly.
With like...
Look at that smile.
I don't know.
Guys.
What am I supposed to do?
Talk to him?
Like we haven't had...
This is...
It's literal flesh.
When has an actual human been in this mid-cafe?
I don't know.
I don't...
What am I supposed to say?
Do I...
Do I possess him?
Do I say boo?
Will he get scared?
Will he leave?
I don't know!
Okay.
I'll be brave.
Okaidinaasai masai gochidin sama, ojo sama?
Are you lost?
They're still there.
Oh, we don't get many customers.
I mean, we get customers.
We don't get many.
Fleshy.
What do I do?
My name is Min Phantom.
Hi.
Fleshy.
Is that okay if I call you that?
Is it okay?
But nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
Hi.
How are you?
Conversation starter.
The weather.
Happening.
You are so alive right now.
Yes.
Oh, so are you hungry?
Did you happen to think that this was a maid cafe, which it definitely is.
This is a maid cafe.
Did you think this was a maid cafe and you came to experience maid and food?
Surely?
Omorize.
Well, you haven't even looked at the menu yet.
Hold on.
You're getting a little ahead of yourself.
Here.
our menu for you and sorry these are our seasonal uh the seasonal stuff let me just uh wait oh geez i don't how do you work a paper clip i don't know uh you can look at those later for now peruse our delicious menu get in there real real real good wow so what we have on the menu today oh oh we have vtuber oh wow oh wow vtuber oh vtuber you can get them age 19.
no forever though it's yeah it's just you know remember that forever forever yeah and And, you know, birthday, birthday, birthday cake flavor tasting.
I don't know what the little past its prime means, though.
Prime sounds like a good thing.
Like, it's prime.
It's peak.
It's peem.
It's, yeah.
October 1st, which has already passed, which...
Um, yeah.
Uh...
very tall 149 centimeters yeah that's this is all the mint phantom everybody yeah this is
very tall no yes also don't ask about my weight why would you do that why would you do that why would you do that let's look at let's look at oh here i'm gonna zoom in a little bit more We'll look at one at a time, right?
You guys have short attention spans, maybe.
Yeah.
And then, you know, I have all of these already.
These are.
In fact, I feel I have seen a few people, maybe one or two, that have done the ghost and the sparkle together.
Where's my subway surfers?
You could literally get your phone.
out at any time but it's very rude I'm talking to you no way yes way yes way so if you're looking for something a little more for a cultured palette I would recommend the hashtag fantography for good for delicious art but I think sometimes people put things in there that might should go in another hashtag
It's a little scary in there, even for me sometimes.
And, of course, for the live stream, that's chef's choice.
Me, I'm the chef.
So, actually, you guys, we might be doing away with the Japanese hashtag on Mito Live.
And just sticking with hashtag Mito Live.
Just for consistency.
I do check both quite often, but I think we'll just keep it in the one.
What do you mean, doe?
It's okay, it's okay.
Next, we have...
I have a plushie.
And if you have that plushie, I would like you to use hashtag mint to go.
Get it?
It's like mint to go, but mint to go.
It's a pun.
But that thing is a very dangerous creature.
And, you know.
And also for general, we're keeping mint to shinde, shashin, but you can also use hashtag mint phantom that is fine as well and then you must be 18 years or age of oh wait wait 18 years oh i i made a typo
uh-oh someone call corporate someone call every
location all our franchise locations will wait look at this that's me right there it's kind of freaky
minor spelling mistake these are my parents my mama I am my mama get it a delightful push of Baja Blast wait why did I laugh at the blast
sorry I'm nervous
And my papa, Celia.
Thank you.
Also, if you ever want to make that thing, it's apparently bourbon and ginger ale and orange slice.
Yes.
And then also, our specialty menu.
Our specialty menu.
you everybody oh ah what could be oh please ask about the character impressions please ask please ask say um ask oh what about the frog say the frog toad toad impression what should i say is toad um yeah for free for free it's crazy right They're flying off the shelves.
People are just stealing them.
Okay, so I can do Kermit the Frog.
Kermi.
Wait, what does Kermit the Frog say?
We'll do that one later.
But for Toad, we can say...
Let's see.
Say where's Mickey Mouse?
Oh, where's my money, Mario?
I read that wrong.
Sorry.
I
think that was really loud I apologize
And then we have the fan name Oh That one has not been Filled out Wait That's a little peculiar, no?
Actually, everybody I have a confession to make I have a confession And and an apology
good evening everyone thank you all for gathering today here thank you very much i actually would like to uh thank you wait i already said that oh thank you for your continued support and uh everybody uh here watching uh the mid-phantom den setu.exe debut question mark because I've already been around for a while.
I would like to say that I apologize for I have kept this secret for too long.
I have a hard time saying the word.
whisper therefore therefore we will be changing names because it triggers my stutter and it's hard to call you guys if I say what's up my whips I struggle to say it therefore I am taking I am taking suggestions and applications for a new name for a new fan name this is not this is not a bit um why are you saying she hates us that's all it
is I just can't say it please understand and thank you for your understanding and
um if you have any suggestions we can um uh you can put them in hashtag mint phantom and i will check and then i should have known from the beginning that it would why do you guys i don't say it very often because it's difficult for me to say anyway thank you again for being here on the stream and back to the show
Anyway, oh, well, okay, that was everything about the creature feature.
I'm telling you, that thing is a gnarly ride.
You are not ready for it unless you've literally done every single thing that I told you to do in the mountains.
Then only then will you feel like you're prepared to take on the creature feature.
Cool!
So you saw the menu.
Oh, whoop.
You saw the menu.
Yeah.
Anything look particularly appetizing?
Mmm.
It's yummy.
Stop it.
I know it all looks so yummy.
Sorry, I'm so close to your table.
and down your neck i'm like this is this is my recommendation you'll take a parent please you want my mom and my dad you want my mom and my dad but yeah just uh just put that there in your lap nice and cozy and snug yeah um oh oh my gosh though
you know I kind of have like a filter on on the camera it makes it makes the maid cafe look quite spick-and-span quite spotless and and me so beautiful but actually actually you know like I said we don't get very many customers so it's a little it's a little like let me just clean up your table for you i'm very sorry sir and well person people there's a lot of you likes kind of squish you guys are like little pickmen all on the all in the chair all stacked on top of each other so so flesh flesh flesh being so uh let me just uh let me just clear your table for you i am so sorry oh gosh how embarrassing oh oh see like oh it's just bad it's it's bad bad oh wow one moment one moment oh let me uh um
what's happening
whatever okay so um let me yes
i'm gonna make this nice and shiny for you guys nice and shiny don't mind the dust okay three two one okay all right let me i've just kind of stored some stuff here so i hope you guys don't mind that it's kind of like it's just a little messy i I apologize.
I'm so so sorry.
Let me let me get this out of the way for you.
Oh my gosh.
We sometimes have vandals.
It's not funny, actually.
I'm so sorry.
That's your coughing.
Please.
Take a moment.
Oh, but look at this.
They wrote some really cute things.
likes of being silly.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, being a silly otaku.
And cute girls and things.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Mount Fuji.
Oh, hmm.
Idols and being a otaku.
Oh, yeah.
I get it, I get it.
Corn soup.
Who wouldn't love corn soup?
Dad jokes.
I do love a good joke.
Yeah.
And E, E, E.
Hmm.
See, I've always heard that people don't like, you know, that feeling when you're like, E!
But liking E, E.
I get it.
Hmm.
I think I understand.
But usually I hear people don't like E.
But I think I like E.
You know?
What's wrong with E?
E.
Ah.
Of course, these things are all so relatable, no?
I think I love every single one of these things.
But actually, isn't that so silly?
Hmm, interesting.
Let's get this, let's also, isn't this spider just so cute, but like, they made a total mess of my, of my, um, my table.
I don't, actually, this is not even mine.
I don't know where this came from, so.
Oh, oh no, dislike, sad.
Spicy food?
Yeah, actually I can't have spicy food either.
You know?
Messes?
Well, I'm a maid, so of course I hate messes and everything.
The jumpy kind.
Okay.
I have like so much...
Okay, like even ladybugs, you know?
I don't even like ladybugs because they jump at me.
Is that weird?
I like them from far away, but I don't like when...
I don't like bugs that go...
You know what I mean?
Oh, hide berries.
Oh, oh,
you're not watching this, are you?
Whoa.
Anyway, um, wearing socks in bed.
Okay, I don't care how cold my feet are.
I don't care.
I don't care how cold my feet are.
I have to not wear socks in bed.
It's like the most uncomfortable feeling for me.
Like I'm always, I will take off my socks.
I'll be in bed and if I accidentally wear my socks, I'm like, Phoebe!
Grippers out always.
I gotta feel free.
Like, I don't know.
I wear socks all day.
So I really love the feeling of taking off my socks in my bed.
You know?
I don't know.
That's just how it is.
And then, when you don't bring offerings to me, of course, as a ghost, I need offerings.
I need sustenance to continue my ghostly, not life.
live it life so bring me snacks please and thank you okay what else we got here let's get my my very my thin books out of the way oh and
oh i i i feel like these have not changed so much in in years i feel like i still love the same things even after all these years I even, like, kind of tried to make it a little smaller, you know?
So I love Steinsuke!
Did you guys see some of the Steinsuke references in the new opening?
And I love YuroKamp!
I love Yoruboy!
It plays further than the universe.
That's one.
I went to Antarctica because of that series.
I love...
Re-zero.
Okay, but Whatever Slop is fine sometimes I love Slop I love idle stuff like wug and iMass And iCarts I love a bunny girl senpai And I love a When They Cry series So I was a fan of Sotsu and Go When they came out Very happy Especially because Akio Watanabe Did the character design for that And so it was like Everything that I love All coming together Gather!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, hmm, I feel like these haven't changed at all.
I think the only thing that's really changed about me is the games that I like.
It's funny.
I mean, I like what I like, so it's okay to enjoy slop.
I agree.
Everybody has a guilty pleasure.
You all are not innocent.
We're in this together.
And I know that because you're here.
Don't think you're better than me.
Don't act like you're better than me.
And last but not least, we have...
Let me move this cardboard box out of the way.
Oh, that's you.
Sorry.
Bye,
Ben.
Don't do this.
Don't leave.
I talked about Re-Zero once and you're already trying to skidaddle out of here.
Games!
Who's scribbling all this stuff on the table like this?
Gosh, you guys could never tell, right?
Because of the filter that I keep on the camera.
You would never know that all of this is on here.
We have Metal Gear Solid!
Metal Gear Solid series.
Maybe like a little bit.
Blue Archive!
I just did my dailies literally right before stream.
as I was panicking.
I was like, am I going to remember everything?
Am I going to remember everything?
Yeah, I think we're okay so far.
Maybe.
Maybe we're okay so far.
So far so good.
Ace Attorney series.
I really love Ace Attorney series.
I love horror games and I love puzzle games and I love horror and puzzle games.
But I also like them separate.
I love Blue Archive.
Oh my gosh, I'm a huge blue.
I don't even know if you could put that under games.
It's a mobile game, it's fine.
I love Toho!
Toho Project.
Konichiwa.
Watashiwa.
Mint Phantom.
Toho Project.
I like this.
Wait, the joke is it's supposed to sound like good Japanese.
And then Toho Project.
My bad.
Blue Archive.
And then I like visual novels.
Though I will say.
I like them.
I have not played so many.
of late because I am so busy, but I am always open to your suggestions.
Yes.
I should, I probably, I don't know.
Maybe I'll play when on the plane.
Or something.
So yeah, these are all the things I like.
Oh, I also forgot.
Oh my gosh.
So in the past, I've talked about having my MP3 player.
and um i've i've had it for like maybe 10 years now or something unfortunately when my last car died i stopped using my mp3 player because now with my new car i'm able to to hook up my um my phone to the car i know but what i have here as you could see is my Isn't it so cute?
Isn't it so cute?
Everybody say, sorry, I'm a little ghostly at the moment.
It's, you know.
But, yeah, I thought it would be fun to show some things that I would, like, listen to while, you know, driving around.
So, let's see.
It's actually in Japanese, not by, because I'm a weeaboo, which is the truth.
Because it was given to me by some Japanese organizers.
And it does not change to English.
It is only Japanese.
So that was fun.
Let's see what we got.
Okay, let's go to album.
And we'll just kind of go through some songs that I would listen to while driving.
So let's see.
I've got some AKB48 on here.
What I...
Oh my gosh.
I like to joke that this is like a graveyard of music.
because there's so many idols in here so many groups and things that just don't exist anymore so like and also what's really cool is I have a bunch of like super indie idol group that I would like buy their CD and then rip it and just groups that also don't exist anymore but like I have like this little bit of history because because I own their stuff so it's kind of fun it's like it feels It feels like a very me type of mp3 player,
song choice.
So we have Dampagumi Inc.
Is this the...
Oh, I did click album.
We have Momo I Haruko.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
I'm trying to...
There we go.
That's better.
Um...
I-Cuts!
Akiba's trip.
Some idols.
Fauna.
I was out on a rap city.
Appare.
The idol group.
Uh...
Let's see.
Idols.
Idol.
Wug.
Wake up, girls.
Kaguya Luna!
Oh my gosh.
So good.
Yeah.
So.
What do you mean it's upside down?
Well, yeah, because I'm on the other side of the table.
I'm not going to sit in your lap, weirdo.
Sorry that it's upside down.
But I mean, I have to look it at myself.
I'm on the other side of the table.
her more idols so bish ogre yui she's my she's my seyu oshi she's my i love her yushi oh milky homes mosaic wave mosaic wave mosaic this also hasn't been updated it's been updated a little bit in that i added metal gear music but other than that everything now i kind of listen to on like Spotify,
so Yumen Minemu Girls Dead Monster, more Kaguya Luna, Danceroid, if anybody remembers them, oh, geez, Detective Conan.
Also, it kind of separates things a little funky, so Yudimeto More, Yomel More is one of my favorite idol groups.
I love them.
I love, love, love them.
Let's see.
Asaka!
Asaka, she's one of my favorite one of my favorite artists So, sorry about the light, by the way.
Let's see.
AKV, AKV.
Zok.
Oh, gosh.
Machiko!
So good.
Oh, Kiari, Pamu, Pamu.
Yeah, that's how you know.
Like, these are so old, no?
More dead idol groups, dead bands.
Come in, Josh!
Yeah, so you can kind of get a little bit of an idea of, like, these songs some of them are like so oh he mehina he mehina i love love love love them let's see bees air awi manikikecha oh just be friends oh my gosh kind of see me calibration i sang that one Somewhat recently.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, under 17!
Under 17!
I love, love, love.
More, more dead idol groups.
Oh, Metal Gears.
Yeah, I told you.
Miko, Miko, nurse.
Yeah.
Momoi, Haruko.
mosaic wave Get him out of more More dead idol groups So more dead idol groups Yeah, so that's a little bit of the music.
I had a list of music artists and I was like it's getting too long So that's a little bit of some groups that I like so yeah Oh now you have a nice oh Hold on, let me get this one more time.
Let me just...
Nice and clean, nice and shiny.
Yeah, oh, wait.
You're not looking so high.
Are you okay?
Are you all right?
I didn't scratch this in the table.
It's not like we don't get customers ever and I was so bored and just scratched it in there.
Why would I do that?
That's like, that's like kind of, that's like psycho behavior, no?
That'd be ridiculous!
What are we talking about?
Look how clean it is!
Look how clean.
Do you want...
Do you want the house tour?
I can take you to the first, second, third floor.
Actually, there's only one floor.
My room.
There's only...
There is only one floor, and it's my room.
And, uh...
Why am I so small?
Oh, my gosh!
What are you doing in my room?
You freaks?
Welcome.
Oh, I think chat is frozen.
Give me a second.
I'll revive you.
Oh, you're revived!
Oh.
A girl's room!
It's a little... It's a little messy.
Just like the table.
But it's okay.
That's fine.
Hi!
Welcome to my room and welcome to my debut!
Thank you, everybody!
It's... It's... I finally get to show off my likes and my dislikes and my... my things and my...
I finally... I got to show it off!
Woo!
Yeah!
So, I don't know.
I think I've only done that once.
So, kind of, kind of fun.
Yeah.
And now if you don't know me very, or if you didn't know me very well, now hopefully you know me a little bit better.
There's a few, of course there's still more.
There's more time before Phoebe and then of course Vicky.
So please, if you could stay around for all three of us.
we have a group collab together where we will be being silly and cute and we will be debuting our original song so and you heard a preview of it probably at the very beginning of the stream of my of my stream so yes yes it's it's a really hype song and please listen to it lots and lots and lots yeah one thing i do want to go over a little bit um is from your menu oh wait this one that's me the seasonal menu it changes depending on the season aka my mood um this is me uh yes i will i will post um both reference sheets on twitter so obviously these are not new they're they're quite the same but um yeah please refer to this with with art and on cosplay and everything so oh and my height 149 centimeters don't forget it don't forget it yeah got so redacted i passed out
Yeah, so that's me, and then I think I'm only, I don't think I've posted this one, but this is the reference sheet for this outfit.
Yeah, nice and cozy, minkity, minkity.
So, yes, I can, I can take off the jacket.
Oh, she's so fast.
How does she do it?
How does she take it off so quickly?
And I can take off the frills.
How exciting, how exciting!
Yeah, so I will post this on twitter.com as well!
So, if you ever want to draw a fan art of this outfit, then here's reference!
And third outfit...
Is coming redacted!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, my chat, there we go.
I was gonna say, my chat broke.
Oh, she's so, Natami.
Oh, hey, so, oh, hey, so, hey, so, hey, so, thank you, right?
Everybody, belly button.
We have belly button enjoyers here in the chat, right?
Yeah.
So, I also wanted to talk a little bit about, you maybe saw the new the new opening Ta-da!
Woo!
Of this scene in particular, I wanted to show you guys a little more of the details in X...
Wait, details in...
Wait.
The...
Show you more of the details in detail.
Wait.
Ah!
Ignore me.
The door.
ignore me but actually um i worked with uh wea she did the animation and um and uh apple knuckles did the background uh they they sent me this too earlier to show like all the different references that they included for isn't this kind of insane it's nuts right it feels like quite literally everything that I love.
And they even included some things that I was like, oh, wow, wait, this was a good thing to include.
So many, so many little details, so.
Very fun, very fun.
I know, even Fatal Frame.
I didn't even ask for Fatal Frame.
And I was like, whoa!
So yeah, please enjoy the new opening anime because I love it so much I love love love it and yeah and then I did forget something that's okay though I'll do it after I'll do it towards the end and all credits will all be updated in the in the description after stream it wasn't because I was too busy to put them in before stream Congrats on the re-debute!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
And so, I also wanted to talk a little bit.
I wanted to kind of, some people are probably like, why even are you debuting?
Like, what?
What is going on?
What is this?
So, what is Denzetsu.exe?
So Denzetsu.exe was created and, oh, it is also owned by me, Phoebe and Vicky.
So, the three of us we came up with with essentially everything like the concept and um and everything that all of our all of our ideas and everything came together through our brains um so we're we're a little we're a little some people describe us as an indie idol group an underground idol group um we just kind of wanted to have like a creative outlet with like um with like an idle focus kind of kind of kind of idea and um we do we have all we have full control over our image everything like we're weird though we're the brains behind this behind this gig and then you might be wondering well you are also working with satsuna who are they
um they're like handling communication related things i have a i have a manager now it's kind of nice so yeah these shady satsuna fellows i you guys feel like my like a dad who's just like i have to vet this person before you date them i have i need to vet this fellow but um but uh Yeah,
they're allowing us to focus more on our creative endeavors while they kind of handle the uh, the, the workload, the paperwork and things like that so that we can be more silly, goofy fun on stream.
And, and you can also get more fun things because there's other people handling stuff.
So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are they good enough for our veto?
Yeah.
So, um uh we are so if you still donate to me we keep all of streaming income so if you're just like where's my money going it's still going towards me and us and our projects so yes yes yes yes so that's just like a little brief um introduction to tinsetsu.exe and satsuna for everybody who is kind of like a little curious and weary and everything very optimistic and we're we're we're all it's a good people so yeah and I have just about 10 minutes left let's see I wanted actually let's head back to the maid cafe real quick because because there was one last thing I wanted to do as a maiden let's go Where am I?
Oh, gosh.
And...
Okay.
One last thing.
Wow.
Koshiditsaba, you fell asleep and you had a very strange dream.
Please, please try not to fall asleep at the table.
It's actually very meiwaku for our other patrons.
Definitely.
are here.
Yeah.
Anyway, because we don't get very many customers, many flesh customers, is it okay if I can say that?
I have a little checklist to go over so that I can be a proper maid.
I don't want to forget anything, you know?
so um um oh how'd that get in there just uh uh don't worry about that worry about my dreams oh as you can see this was updated i literally wrote this list october 9th 2024 i have a i know that because that's the date that i posted it in discord yeah in my private like i have my own discord like that nobody else is in just me where i can like write notes i'm sure i feel like a lot of people have that so so some of these might be a little outdated um let's let's go through and then maybe we can make some new dreams and goals together if that's okay so first i want to collab with an idol group i want to collab with an idol group maybe like a Japanese idol group maybe some group that I really really love or something yeah that's been that's been a dream of mine for a really long time so yeah yeah yeah I want to see Minto cosplay and Dojin at Comic-Camp but I feel like I feel like I could cross out the Dojin at least the Dojin part because technically Ayami Mama has released a dojinchi of
me at Comic-Cat!
Or at least not, well, she released a dojinchi that I am in at Comic-Cat, so...
Yeah!
Guys, why are you blushing?
Dojinchi is not always so edgy, okay?
Yeah.
But...
Well, I'll save this for later.
Then, we can cross out concert!
Cross out!
And do a 3D concert live!
I've done both!
That's kind of insane!
Oh, oh my gosh.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it!
I can't believe I've done both.
Yeah!
This one might be kind of out of nowhere.
I want to learn how to DJ.
I kind of want to become like an Anikura DJ.
And DJ at and like maybe host my own Anikura event one day which is like basically they just play anime songs and people do calls and are silly and it's fun yeah i'm into ab mogra one day one day maybe i also want to make a haunted house maybe at like like an event or something like even if it's just kind of i just want to design it you
I want to maybe one day make a haunted house And you guys go through it And then tell me it's 10 out of 10 super spooky I will make number 2 happen Well, I'll wait for it then Oh
I want to sing an opening song for a visual novel
Yep That is one of my goals One of my goals, one of my dreams.
That's also been a dream for a while.
And then I think the last time I met up with Ayami Mama, she was just like, she was like, Minto, my goal for you is to reach 1 million subscribers.
And I think that if I ever reach 1 million subscribers, then maybe I could probably ask Ayami Mama to make that kind of doji.
An official.
So...
We'll see if it ever happens.
That will be my 1 million subscriber goal.
And I would also like to get to 1 million subscribers one day because I've never had that many ever before in my afterlife.
So it would be really cool to see, I think.
Yeah!
Yeah.
And then...
My last final dream is to possess you and make you happy!
That's a Minto goal for me, Minto.
I wrote that.
Yeah!
So, will you...
Will you...
Will you let me possess your body and...
And, you know, I won't do anything illegal.
Maybe.
I don't know human laws.
or the laws of your country so um but i'll i'll treat it i'll treat it and take care of it and uh you'll you'll return once i'm gone uh you'll return to your body nice and full is it okay is it okay love ya love ya love ya
okay yes yes yes Yay!
Then I will possess you very lovingly!
We still have a little bit of time left, so right before...
Oh, you know what they have at maid cafes?
As you see that stage back there?
You can request a song!
Would you like a song that I can sing for you?
Say yes, say yes, say yes, yes.
Yeah!
Let me see.
I have a song already pulled up!
Let's...
You know, I'm just gonna sing it right here by the table because you're the only one here!
So...
I picked... I picked a very...
Otaku...
This might be nostalgic for some of you guys, so...
Let's sing!
Oh, wait.
Wrong thing.
There we go.
1 2 3... 1 2...
1... 1... 1...
1... 1...
1...
1... 1... 1...
1... 1...
1...
Keep
me up!
Keep me up!
Don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew don't chew!
I love him
Don't I miss you I'm not forever I don't know I don't know That's my whole
me give me a move me i can't
be i live without you Why, why, why, why, why, why, don't I believe you more, forever I know, that's a secret I'm always in my heart, I'm in my heart
Yay!
The song is Marissa stole the precious thing from Toho.
Ayo sis!
Yeah!
Go sing, go, sing, go, sing, go, sing, go, sing, go, sing, go, sing, go, sing, go, sing,
I would listen to the song before I even knew what Toho was!
Thank you, everybody!
Thanks for the debut!
Go watch Phoebe!
Support!
Tencent 3XE!
Thank you!
Bye!